Now imagine that this yellow sheet of
paper is the Python Standard Library. Imagine that
this is what we got when we downloaded Python. Inside Python is a file named
webbrowser. And inside webbrowser is a function
called open. Now this is the function that
allowed us to play the YouTube video.
Much like webbrowser, there is another file or
module inside the Python Standard Library. It's
called time, and time has several functions
defined inside of it. Two of them are, ctime which gives you the current time,
and sleep, which suspends program animation for
a little bit. Now here's a thought, how
does function sleep actually suspends or pauses
program flow for a given number of seconds?
We don't really know how it does that behind
the scenes. In much the same way, how does
function open, opens up a webbrowser to play a
YouTube video for us? We don't quite know how it
does that behind the scenes also. That detail is
hidden from us, and this hiding of detail in programming
is called abstraction. Now this idea of abstraction is
a really powerful one in programming, because it allows us
to focus on the program that we actually want to write which
is the take a break program, and it empowers us to use
these functions simply by reading their
documentation. So let's read some documentation
now and see if these functions actually exist in the Python Standard Library.